my name is Hassan I am the author and
maintainer of plot 9 a grammar of
Graphics visualization system in
Python now in
2011 we had an election in
Uganda I was not satisfied with the
breadth and depth of the analysis that
showed up in the media so I wanted to
know more
home so I learned Python and dove into
the data when it got to the
visualizations I felt the experience
could be better I looked around and
discovered gig plot 2 an implementation
of the grammar of Graphics in the r
programming language now this was the
most elegant idea I had come to know of
and I wanted to use it in Python I did
not think I could implement it but as it
was was a great idea and great ideas
spread I expected someone more capable
than me would implement it in Python so
I waited after 2 years something came
up in Python but I was dispirited when I
used it it was a surface level imitation
of a Gramm of Graphics it's it was like
slapping the body of a super car onto a
regular car nonetheless I contributed to
that effort to make it better and in
doing so I gained the confidence that I
could implement the grammar of Graphics
in
Python and I also took ownership of the
project that is how plot 9 came to
be now I have stressed the phrase a
bunch of
times what is one word that comes to
your mind when you hear grammar of
Graphics Take 5
Seconds
if you have struggled to nail down what
it evokes that is okay even if you are
familiar with the concept but how about
a definition what is the grammar of
Graphics well this is just a language
and rules to make statistical Graphics H
probably that doesn't add much
understanding because it is possible to
be able to Define an idea yet not
understand it and the vice versa to
understand an idea yet be unable to
Define it but to me that definition is
adjacent to the words and idea that the
words grammar of Graphics evoke in my
mind likely because I am quite familiar
with the concept when I hear language
and
rules my mind asks how do I put things
together how do I compose stuff in that
system and grammar of Graphics brings to
mind composing
visualization so we are going to explore
the power and elegance of a system that
is built to be used through composition
of its components the components are we
have the data we have the Aesthetics we
have the scales we have statistics we
have positions we have geometric objects
we have facets we have coordinate system
we have theming
but we have already acquired a suspicion
for premature definitions so we shall
just go along and experience the
components directly but first let's
introduce our data set we are going to
look at um subset of the Palma Penguins
data
set this is a data set of size
measurements of three penguin species
observed on three islands in the
Antarctica ours is stripped down to
these three variables we have the
species the bill length and the sex we
are going to take a narrow look at the
bill
length
often we want a graphical summary of a
continuous variable a box plot is an
example of such a summary so let us
start with that first we import all the
components for easy exploration then
declare a gram of Graphics plot looking
at the Penguin's data set in the
Aesthetics we map the Y aesthetic to the
B length and add a box plot
geometry we get one box plot for all the
Penguins we can add a box plot per
species to do that we map the X
aesthetic to the
species but before we
continue let us stream the X and Y
keywords we can do that if they are the
f two parameters if you are coming from
GG PL 2 and from
R the most obvious difference that you
see and you will experience with plot 9
is that the Aesthetics are wrapped in
strings are use strings wrapped in
quotation marks so let's continue that
gives us three Bo box plots one per
species let's give the species a
different color so we
map the species to the color
Aesthetics and we get a different color
for each species now coloring the
species coloring by the species does not
add any information we shall change that
later for more information we can add a
mean comparing means and medians gives
us a simple way to detect
SK to do that we compute a summary
statistic using the mean function
visualize it as a column geometry and
fill it with
color and we
get
boxes two types of boxes the column box
and the Box PL but we still have a lot
more information trapped within the
individual points all the all the
information about the variability of the
of of um of the be length is still
trapped within the points let us
visualize them we add a point geometry
for
that the points are over plated a common
solution to that is to vary change the
opacity to something less than one we do
that uh change it to half opacity
0.5 but that doesn't change much maybe
add some Jeter to it that is another
common solution to overplotting so we
set the position to J and we get a
something like a strip plot overlaid on
top of the box
plot but the distribution is still
largely hidden how about we swap the box
plot for a violin we replace the violin
geometry with the we replace the box
plot geometry with the violin
and we get
violines but with that plot we have lost
the Precision of the
fiveo summary that the box plot gives us
but we have gained a better sense of the
distribution depending on your context
this may be the right decision but
something isn't right with the points
they are Wayward imagine if we could
squish them into the violins
if there are enough of them they could
by themselves convey a sense of the
distribution like
that looking at that we do not really
need the
violin in fact we have danced along the
motivation for a fairly recent type of
plot called a c plot it came around in
2017 and there is a geometry for
that
giom
CA and that gives us information about
the density distribution the number of
points their variance and outliers
amongst
them this plot still isn't perfect let
us refine it we have a rectangular
column because it was easier to use at
the time but it is displaying a point
statistic so a line segment is a better
choice
so we introduce a line
segment we use the same statistic and
function as the
column we set the color to Black so that
we have black lines for each of the
species stretch it out to match the
column uh the width of the column which
is 90% of the available horizontal space
and the Y value is constant it is the
mean so the seg M aligns with the top of
the column that is some crosschecking so
with that we are done with the need for
um the bulky column so we shall remove
it and we have our C plot with black
lines for the means but we also note
that the
exposition and the color of the means
convey the same information so the color
is is redundant the type of species we
can change that we shall let the color
represent the uh the sex of
the Penguins we change that and that
separates the points for each of the
species along the
Sexes and that also introduces another
problem clearly each
species the difference for each species
the different Sexes have different means
let us add segments for those
means now this is a mechanical process
we start off with the segment we already
have we copy it we paste it we remove
the fixed color to let it inherit the
global color for the
sex
and the result is you can barely tell
the difference between the two segments
but it gives
us means for each of the Sexes for every
species but there's something wrong with
that the colored segments overlap their
territories they need some type of they
need the same type of positioning as the
C geometry and the box plot before it so
the default position for the C geometry
is to dodge that is not to overlap along
the xais in the same layer we tell the
dodging system that the
lines occupy 90% of the available width
and it does the right
thing and that gives us our nice um
segments Now using the text
geometry we can add
counts to each of the
groups the uh each of by the sex for
each of the species in the
group
and we set the label to the number of
points in the group format it as n
equals and still with the summary
statistic we find the lowest point and
set the Y aesthetic to a value below the
minimum calculated we we are doing some
math where we subtract a value of one
and that um should give us uh text that
does not overlap the points and what we
get is that counts in each group that
are placed at the same precise distance
below the lowest point in each
group
and let's
make the colors more vibrant
now those colors are generated by a
default color scale we
can vary the parameters slightly to give
them a pop and we get something like
that but the our problems have not
ended the colored line segments and the
points are the same
color let us differentiate them though
the difference has to be small because
they represent the same group we want
the
colors to be close enough in
space so we have to do color math just
like we have done position math to have
the text for the counts come in below
the lowest point and that color math is
going to be to darken the colors we use
this utility function which takes a
lines uh which takes a list of colors
and some factor and it darkens them by
that factor for
example on the
right you can see the top uh we convert
um we transform the top uh the list of
colors at the top by uh various factors
and the results are are what you see
at the bottom a fact of One turns any
color black using this
function for the desired line
segments we darken them by a factor of
025 and we have our final plot and there
we are we have easily stacked point
geometries and adjusted their positions
and colors in the process created a
visualization um that we can at best
call a c plot because that is the most
complex of its component geometries
otherwise it has no name it was it was
not prepackaged the grammar of Graphics
made it easy to compose specifically the
layered grammar of Graphics made it easy
to
compose our first task has been to get
to grips with the
concept as you have seen it from my
perspective the next question is is a
little different if you know something
about the grammar of
Graphics what
question that question could go like
this can the grammar of Graphics help me
with my problem the next example is
inspired by GitHub user Jonathan Vitali
who asked for help to create Graphics of
a for a guitar skill trainer using plot
9 uh again we start with the data which
is called the data to be to be
visualized it will look like that for
each string a fret to hold down while
plucking the string but this is the
userfriendly format we have a function
that turns it into uh a format that is
friendly for plotting uh we since we are
going to be looking at a guitar fret
board let us Define um our plotting
function we give it data it plots
something like that that is our starting
point we stretch uh we can um edit the
theme to stretch it out give it funky
color remove the grid
marks and it's starting to take shape we
add some markings within the
canvas and U the standard dots then the
Frets then the strings we add diameters
we give we give it an accurate gauge so
if you are familiar with the guitars you
um you may you may know what that is and
and for convenience we bundle all this
into a a
list and we get a template everything up
to that point has been familiar we did
that in the first part which is
composing but what makes this
interesting is to get an accurate
representation of a guitar we have to
create a custom scale that means we have
to use some math that the the same math
that guitar makers use to create guitars
the key requirements for custom scale
are the
domain knowing the domain of the data
our guitar scale our guitar scale will
will have um 22
Frets that a transformation function
oops that this were and an inverse F
function and how to calculate the
brakes and using the misani package
which is a key requirement for for plot
9 we create a trans object which is like
filling in a
template
and after
the the after uh sorry um the that that
trans object did not appear but we use
it to create a scale
and we
get the Frets and evenly distributed to
show the nonlinear of the guitar scale
and with that we get to visualize the
final code that we are going to be
looking at which is the c major code and
that those are the geoms that visualize
the code and thank
[Applause]
you